et vous allez entendre quatre comédiens
extraordinaires fermez les yeux est ce
que vous allez faire connaître attention
numéro je jure solennellement que mes
intentions sont mauvaises yet billets
scénique et délits
ça veut dire pas de soucis et vous les
airs connus mais je vous laisse un
commentaire maintenant on comprend
chansons d'amour à son côté le baril
une autre a su soigner
au levant eu vent et c'est ton fils à sa
patte on n'est qu'un tout quoi c'est ton
fils à ses pattes à ma faim non mais tu
lui chante une chanson d'amour non non
pas du tout non
[Musique]
est ce que c'est un combat c'est le
petit écran plat le réalisateur regarde
ce qu'il est en train de tourner
il ya deux types d'acteurs électeurs
quand il a fini sa prise comme un petit
chalet regarder derrière un combo il va
regarder comment il est ensuite les
acteurs qui disent je ne regarde pas
comment je joue je fais confiance à
l'autre eh bien moi je suis dans l'autre
catégorie catégorie de celui qui ne se
regardent pas jouer tous les acteurs qui
si on regarde jouer nous font perdre
chaque fois le temps de la prise herman
kesters barça oui si c'est quoi le
comble pour un homme tronc non c'est
resté planté là
tu sais à quel cheval il manque un bout
circoncise
c'est monsieur et madame amberg ils sont
du nord une jeune fille comme ray
s'appelle
ce pas anaïs anaïs berry
a les boules moi je savais que j'étais
hyper lax mais là j'ai vu une photo
il ya un petit problème au niveau de du
bras
ah
mais
tout va bien
ça va super
bon voilà je suis en train de nous dans
les alpes et franchement c'est cool
j'espère juste que sur le chemin je veux
pas croiser des grosses vaches
[Musique]
oh je crois qu'elle l'a mal pris